jeden tag gegen sechs beginnt für die 15
jährige die ihre arbeit ihr arbeitsplatz
in die straßen in ihrem viertel im osten
der indischen hauptstadt neu delhi
es ist laut hier und gefährlich totti
ist auf der suche nach plastikflaschen
zeitungen und pappe was andere wegwerfen
kann sie zu geld machen
wir brauchen das sammeln um als familie
überleben zu können mein vater ist krank
meine mutter verdient auch nicht mein
bruder und ich arbeiten damit die
familie über die runden kommt drei bis
vier stunden ist sie normalerweise
unterwegs
nicht immer hat sie glück und findet
viel in der hierarchie der indischen
gesellschaft steht sie ganz unten
die menschen begegnen uns nicht
respektvoll
manchmal werden die mädchen von männern
angepöbelt manchmal gibt es schläge weil
die leute glauben wir würden stehlen
wenn die flaschen sammeln dann landen
wir bei der polizei und die misshandelt
uns dann 40 rupien umgerechnet etwas
mehr als 50 eurocent bringt ein kilo
flaschen beim müll händler wichtiges
geld fuer yuppies familie alle zusammen
leben sie unter einer brücke oben rechts
und links donnert der verkehr tag und
nacht täglich muss die familie damit
rechnen dass sie vertrieben werden kann
denn hier zu bleiben ist eigentlich
illegal totti ist die erste aus der
familie die versucht dieses leben hinter
sich zu lassen
ich wünsche mir dass du die es weiter
bringt im leben
wir führen ein leben als nomaden sehr
unsicher immer von der gnade der polizei
abhängig es ist gut dass du dir einen
anderen weg einschlägt
nachdem flaschensammeln geht es für
totti in den unterricht lesen schreiben
rechnen aber auch sogenannte life skills
stehen hier auf dem stundenplan
regelmäßiges zähneputzen zum beispiel
gehört dazu an rund 100 orten in neu
delhi betreibt die ngo kettner zentren
für kinder von der straße finanziert aus
spenden und durch stiftungen auch in
jobs viertel gibt es so ein zentrum mit
anderen straßenkindern macht studie mit
bei ballack lama zu deutsch
kindergeschichten die ließ einziger
zeitung von und für straßenkinder
es ist redaktionskonferenz die letzte
ausgabe wird besprochen und diskutiert
was soll thema im nächsten blatt sein
eine telefonhotline für kinder in gefahr
seit zehn jahren gibt es die zeitung die
idee kam von den kindern selbst sie
wollten ihre eigenen geschichten
erzähler ballack mama gibt uns die
gelegenheit einmal selbst zu entscheiden
wir entscheiden was wir tun und sind
unabhängig keiner macht uns druck was
auf die titelseite und was hinten in der
zeitung stehen soll
jyoti wünscht sich für die nächste
ausgabe eine geschichte über kinder die
von den drogen losgekommen sind
drogenkonsum bei straßenkindern ein
problem das sie kennt wenn ein kind sein
bild in der zeitung sieht wird es sich
bewusst dass es jemand ist
so ging es mir auch als ich mein bild
zum ersten mal in ballack nahm abgesehen
habe fühlte ich mich richtig gut und bin
öfter als vorher ins lernzentrum
gegangen andere kinder motivieren
vorbild sein
totti nimmt das ernst deshalb geht sie
heute nacht hamburger ein müllsammler
slum
sie will den jüngeren zeigen wie wichtig
lernen ist und als reporterin hofft sie
auch immer auf gute geschichten heute
bekommt sie gedichte zu hören
auch die erscheinen in ballack nahm
irgendwann mal professionell als
journalistin zu arbeiten
totti kann sich das vorstellen
ich möchte anderen gerne eine stimme
geben straßenkinder tun eine menge tolle
sachen und allen problemen zum trotz
wollen sie ihrem leben einen sinn geben
das möchte ich gerne zeigen für die
kinder in tamura da ist jogi schon jetzt
ein vorbild es ist ein langer weg heraus
aus der armut aber die hat den ehrgeiz
ihm zu gehen und irgendwann vielleicht
ganz weg zu sein
vom müllsammeln